alright let's get started
so first of all i would like to say
thank you from no minute idea and gudde
lotto buntinx de bout joined us
community and with that i want to cut it to
give you an this is getting in kentucky
forest is the project take so cool
and this will be a referees i finished
package size doesn't really small but
it's really cool and interesting and and
hobbit sky and make you change the way
you think about the
coach moment so my name is alexander
in the dear kiev and the war for dennis
company culti canonical and this said the
canonical yes bye
very interesting things but the sides of
the fulltime job
also work and can do the side
product code michael storm and the likers
restart the parents who hackathon george
lucas on the gallery some friends of mine
how to view  self saabs through the
night and the yes just participated and the
van
bad helps you will have of the the
hackathons you great sins away and you
just forget about what we were quite
excited about this time i did and its
node.js are mongodb and reload  us
supreme jeff sweetness stuff here in
has me each time took directly related to
the jealous crypt did so who lives it
your boosting would we wanted to release
the things and probably the most
important thing the loonse say oh my
korea the way you
ship the coat letters  letters in the
views be he will be the meters for
the business with this knife as if for the
small or developers happinez is such a
kiss you doing something you write the
go theo koot immediately of vast
reached ik users you feel happy
otherwise you right in  the code doesn't fit
becoming a repository for your something for
romantic for us that something that i
colored edgar degas dit how fast die
jewels farmer for anyone and import eagle
arrival 3 lily bed the time right in the
dead cold and the thousand meadow what you
lack  technology used as and girls
become languages
he caught the woods wheelie important is
that you can quickly
nice coat would workout from jews out of
a box
into some more than they excel users
could reach it
if
yes you can see the light kit
post production master this is  just an
example
with the war point my point is it should
be easy
you should be just small step thousand net
is it great quotes edges shell script
obatala or press the button
it should be easy for anyone you just
promote things'
en ja das war 3  of 4 started with the
light store we want you to move fixed we
wanted to show a coat in really really
quick nana
zo
of course the coach moment is the
problem de china the neighborhood yesterday this
success for a discord time and eat in
was already the  garden and the rechange picos die
technology change and programming
languages ​​popularity change a
sonic force
nyc gharlane clothes we luschen
cycle or the coach moment is the somethin
this forever is that cap and the base that
platform is a service your problem what
is you holding the  ball third michaeli good
implementations like share or no jutsu
for you simply great your account your
very way to the wafer bush and the
colt from the by-the-door is is a short
hair and you do the sphinx local
iq-boost detail it a  video browser
browser your url and you even see it
and this is the way we like to work
done you can quickly
see you then tick your long users
potential users we have can quickly
see that so we started with the app fok
and we have a wide  i have with the app for
be cause you black mini dress is the
pound of experience of the point which it
easy you can run die ef die prey
comment and wouldn't this is the was really
cool you have a big jack you guys
because of you
technical  challenges and with with
canine and yogis such is
executive ingrid way this will be fast
you can cap for a day machine we only now do
how that fold the god with
unfortunately the time you want to
have public religion want you to go
out for a for
public beta let's say who wanted to have
themselves an action diggle's booty is the
private user doen and yours could
just exposure to the city and coat button
jones on-ride kindu ssl is nature
problem but instead of the personal
account you give the switch the  business
one so instead of twente box promotion
jona on a warm heart white and 20
and this absolutely lovies me if this trip
you already have idea manners and great
job there review in which the site blog yuria
us
new nat small but my group business
let's say  it could give you my show us
your time you with your nights weekend
en iv tones about money you think
alright yes the something that i could not
take om so the tango ria lists those
scans train
it was yes person in the was a relapse
apricot one  other student weekend go
further
we can arrange weekend week which will be
private server and the bios is on law
what make you feel my path
but instead of releasing in the end of
the week week will be releasing the end
of the next month sam select in this
personally  here more riri libie set up so
we start the tick you build the end
becomes owners and just by chance he knew he
said remember why case here was
this tweeter high key user we have
or see that project take the buy
and sell the ball the  slider beer was so
my point your is that
doko is something that allows you to
laugh
ek indoor pass this you can run around your
eyes around you also a machine and the wild
you can sustainably select time around your eyes
you can in guy boy
lightweight coach  moment paf
what do we have 2 is 6
but it shine by the think that you
don't want de spent a lot of time on
that give you want to be and jews my i
want to develop the product noordveld
na per switched on drugs and time
sign and stuff you might him in
feeling that you need eps life
experience but you don't you actually
for some reason can choose your or not
use or whatever
sudoku is is de hack by bright hacker
god jeff lynne sea and it's actually one
hundred of lines of the best script
maybe do your the feelin like you use
in the go go go
so is the timing see it s it's that
when myself well so I would rather I
one here and yes from the site these kind of
rights where you  midi the cloned
repository rice wheat that michonne
machine from driving salt and this was not
exactly what we need it that time i chose
the most view features with those guys
would be yes how is windows pro that
rosita real cool he said to request so
is there  in twee your for days
we make it the way it worked really work
for all product en in a few days
with a few days
wie loon [ __ ] en youtube also wel zo en
ik was a great experience and the detail
mars in de drie jack yes  colin in front of
mirror recent photo myself waalwijk i
would like to be viewed and chocolate
experience with us
so
die u
to show you how cool is that
hell expensive a little dream on
of die of the coaching prey bent zo
have dove orange dan bij virtual
machine right  now
and he's gonna be fun just your show you how
how it feels like
so
he just have that docu meets the you
can see gulp lippy kids home is
from your local
dokkum you just in alias soldier and have
a two three wheels simple node.js
application  is this kiellyxx price joss
whedon one of you say the experience of
moby dick big from the my war
machine hours after that is q is doko is
wheels [ __ ] earth is here
we gobble him and i demand you scirocco
before
all of you that's
how you become  doe is we have you
elias for remote repository in your point
out the tu
die machine became the docu is a solids so what
you do next is that your jayegi bos and
the
die take or it local and
repos
local die fold en usa for master
and some major create in the so ham'
bush and the code and it's o'right
you puss together samsung details here and
who building your notes simple
application and
in this really the something node.js design this
application and its own right
this  node.js waslotion
zero dot and in pm version age so and
fashion those node.js binaries so right
now what is do is preparing the wire
and enter an application in
and so ours is warm and this ready is
installs that already which is the vengeance  this
application caps hats in pm a chair
simply have set boom you're ready the
emergency simple doko that not so i'm gon' g
oh
own suppose to close baby for
and this is that express application that
they cool
so kissing they decided to  change some
things you can see is the yoshi and
zero the time so hi can
apply some patient might change would be
just potion app for that
and thanks to a can't
cross china and cried nice so excited
his bike the bad guy and entertain you
fire and  i wanted to face strings
there is possible and push and d2
and i think that something from the
very beginning
something and the student it's no justification
ign it's got affairs the environment for
my education i can i have to install the
dependency and it should  write sorry for
go back to the browser hi concealer my
movies josh diploid
zo dit is feels exactly like experience
with het ook mee en probably views
technology die output that you can see
is doen je similaires 2
hoe die something you can see his goal
zo
ivago  back to my slide glenn
one hundred of lines of the shell script
can you dear this is fake will this
here you can always staff
is that guy this village is i say
ends war settings of course
it's not what it stayed on  the shoulders
of giants the view project that actually
make it possible
en he would like to jazz letter light
highlight what the production cost all of
those
ajax you like my cue they also bonded there
delco something deal table the three major
vinckx
inhabitants cold aggressive
like me  you often see jeff lynne so thick
it received this small components duke
in die fold on your linux machine your
server and i there through time machine to
something that could
exactly
ssc-ict
yogis will master protocol the
kitties or the great so the fortress that  you
see you a fact boost the gutter old and he
pointed to the my machine is i tell you
the gate received component just the
stencil right and receive in the gutter well
and be thousand chasse okay archive der
this is the stream
and run and i at  someone what a because so
this is that either the gate
second doko the something that duo
interesting things as start it and the
rear gravel refer to the sirocco
that is ideal fines i said i learned cm
is you seen the new patient euro buy
in my week  is big is if i want can
2nd open source in lead and u wanna de
tick this idea on kind is the cold
biotex
subtle task so simple simple and a flat
c as the tube creep
this can to the stent they just to just
this clip  so i the text becomes can
you or applicazioni half
is the beer spiaggia ruby ​​on rails and
node.js and then it realize that i could
prepare the execution and wine and of
course they pass such an actual en knew
about node.js u see  the fact of emergency
depending on the ocean sp seafight in the
pq john for ruby ​​on rails the white
vest ruby ​​on rails for jello
it's going to be a big thing visually and sonically
job is to prepare the wire and and to
run the obligation in
and the
india is  is at its i said i dear how
it works smelled in the giro cubicus made
it possible to use
it as they open source time en doko is
reline
discover components and finally
what makes you wonder where exactly something
thinner
is die
product naming dokker
and how  many of you he shot the ball
docker before
javi of us think it is currently you
like so evolino is on your lot of
people talking about learns in a
tweeter and
and he can use it usually go dhabi cupboard
yes i just really interesting is desk
list  nephew for months ago
at the campaign take the dat clot and so
and so growth simplemente time are my
heart
dr in the business of base led they
for five years and they have of course
they get lead the flex pool tits
holes lot of knowledge of  the shipment
of the gold for mission eat mission bay
what if ambitious
d3 allah is the hell decor of china
song or this containers so you want
every beer and later did you do that the
parents that costs things that to clean it
up what they realize you  start to write
it from the scratch it could be to date
to the end is a number at the end so did
decor
no yes no problem really really
good and the stijn in what i say
not to pay you also which the
languages ​​to do not copy  tendon the
left back if he love previews
infrastructure short was a by phone but
that one they decided to right angle
and the
animal implemented and open source and this
is something that regard china is the
village logic and you can check it out in
the dark that he  on that url
yes and whale prepare and the interpreter riders
was drinking alex small box containers
sets
jaap rejet technique all a police
tap that photo just explainit in the view
word and a like the minutes before
cells my hikes use for series of
girl and the
in edge en de shipment of the goods like
one hundred years ago
if you want to use you de stuff from one
place eat meat die je patagonia place
it to boxel barrels have
your budget cheap
then you we have lot of kinshasa is
dat she comes  to to the harbor would it
be enough you know infrastructure unlike
cream to florida point powder than your country
so here have lot of things to think
about
en in the middle of the fours the
situation is ready clichés because people
and when ted containers hoes mittal
box is with a specific dimensions
which you just put the function in close
the door
fine label
you got china germany and growth by
phone and you village i teach ucl in that
to the standard you will not have any
uploads yet with that because it's not
under  the containers
is also the infrastructure window that you
have good enough ships to buddha in good
enough grants to buddha to keep and
sonic frost so that side dna in that
docker project is somethin this [ __ ]
hosta let's say your executable process
is have process something is
and it must me pattern in a weather
repeatable and consistent wcd ra machine
which is one in the doctor and here have
the applications which should start at
insided also there also guarantee your
head and dcm exact figure out what i'm
sure your at it  h we now have
johannes so
and the docu
is use in the container to actually
london ots
application we so something emergency house
aandewiel show machine another patient
i already want to put greasy in
instead it creates the
in had the doctor hes this would shirt
arm is  the after all and the 10 girls seems
the base based application from were
container well start from
so we have the emails about that
prepared with the bild bild pa sorry team
jack this in led she
and that output it your steam is actually
something which has  produced
is the work of the canteen
so the dokker something like this container cd
and the dokker itself is the based on the
linux kernel chip co l i see how they
stein's for linux containers and this c
something that cor functionality or for
operation system but so  if you probably
start to just play around with its
really hard to get any means or result
and this doko is i sure implementation
would make it easier to use
span tons of time to to just realized
how how the finnish helsinki work so little
bit about your core i5 go back hours he
got the machine be document installed
and of course its him in the darkroom
yes so
what he would like to show you quickly
is  there something i describe zoey
have an images
and have square or ladies not a good
yes you can see that what you see this
is the program image step is the image
which do good use and then en start a
new application
and have plenty of them  and you can run
he now lives in site that i miss
you can say doctor to and usp seafight
outgoing my god said something here and
do machine and ecodrome an account of
coomans so as jc biem buijs
my sils
and this is the x i youtube  or that coming
insight i a theme and it's actually
the local system to or did privately
can toe
so the containers a highly is already eat the
process
roegies straw the garden this came and tinder
to
entry member completely i sit it so the
time something i  see something and this comment is
hit in fact can t after he hobbit mix
in peter censorship guy's guide release
rival on purpose on purpose did you
tricks hurt and the yes he mossen
client again to that to that stuff so
what was important is
weil am rhein die one side of comment
like and use the miners the property gia
tour aan het kan de on the background
they cane us the hash well
you can see this here lucas
whatever you're on inside the container
you change the sting
you can run the process which for
instance write something to the file
system
where is you doing that interview
application is dun that you're not
actually change a dbc miss lucas every
time you run it actually and james know
and real time i truetones the  us kids
run and its absolute lewis time if you
want to preserve that you have she could
n't jog not and danny have
cheryl c chai tea with driver and
thymus
it means that you can drive you think
you can run off get for instance to
install mangga  as you can run up get to
install stockings red you can't have
that and well you have base after all so sorry
the bridge mayn't in warmond and becomes
salsacool the ball dived there got it the
public index is a gift of the public
repository that you  can push your base
here with handlebars and other people could
very very easily reviews dat zo in
May-June few have your local development
in warmond in one day image you had to
oudenalder developer studio timo jazz
reviews en der destin you're code where
i  in the x-act in warmend where it's
gonna be executed
something like that with smiles miles before you like to
give you a chance
i was dit is wat de which machines
problem solving
en ja in in ede in the concepts dhd
looks really see muller lucas de  headset
pc girl now can it bad guys can
you believe that
wheelchair machine cool is fixed
is a contain a
so this is the hall process and edge and the
image to show the music show that take
take some time to blood
the and the operation  system started and
music you something you go
through decisions for decisions and such a
dokker is highly
lsc
performance in that this thing was really
fast and you get you out the function in
zo course doctor
to host the containers this is where the
applicazione started and for node.js and
politics about what the oil you
never
etps started to specify the port
c3000
and den dark but i s'pose io port you
can map something with for something om johan
dc5
5555 and that's where you can  use it in
your machine
you can use the the results and you can
read it from the airport
so finally you can have the war machine
be your physical machine with your
machine then you're on and views
applications of in all kees we have
warm she  en it runs through the phone
and tablet cases hoes jono accessible
by my domain take it i sample this
came then you may have epi that i are
bol.com somethin after i are bol.com
all of that is being orchestrated at
a jeep and the  time you install jocko and
boys junior of solin city it comes
with en jacks
so ing band not to regret thumbs up
figure and that i was the time the
deployment of application gives the
sides of the preparation of the doctor
instance
knows a a butch word application
designer it also create the small and
jacks configuration is it alright for
the private person the take away toilet's your this
job scream you read it from the airport
and that port is i put you the execution
of the container and it just
keep mate so guys yeah a  hope mix it in
little chance for you je students
get this or you they said beat it up to
you to this sound descried left
techniques lee in morales but what they
want to share my is dx pr en scout die
docu help hss-r din send  door via
waiting for a long time that we want
you to have a product to be released to
just use doko and the i said dress cm
x pio and sleek we have in the scent also
on the local it's not of course they
kuroko no  it's something really really
small de use you the feeling clap your
use and their soldiers try to buddha
vinckx together and
hopefully you we then
big boy sheen and this is
clear it received component autoplay
your teeth are standing alright here is it
someone is physiognomy arjan de standard
en naira in the shell script and this is
where the docks start to mark this she is
okay got the base dokker email with  about
that insult image text install' dan time
wat in je to use to reject let silk
sources of the application there and run
the field of
en bill door is the scrub is something red
hood is serious of the beagle pups en de
tryin to detect what  i scarf in warm and
go it's node.js branches and
so on you find this covers it iguana
install' de in warmend there and then
dokker chemnitz 13 girl so you have the
image with our die know one and your
application and  executable in were
mentor to this something reusable
in bike christ and it open some time of
course what you need to use just to
restore this image from the begin in
your region application ryan exactly the
same as you the prior to day singles
ethics she claimed simon  warm and access
clients cm wide
so this dockers as all those plans and
dark is and nathan fence
with why are very high and be so he said
i started for months ago in october
you have those plants
walking shiro release their ambitions
guys and they have february
and dc's plans to proceed with the dark
and finally the engines is the one you're
coffin points it city pier city ps stuff
so be cause you might have a lot of fun
instances in want physical machine and and
success the desperation balancing patch your
growth principle already we cyperaceae vinckx
zo for
as though cow was something that
asset and role was to proceed with a
little product en riele en plush
grizzly your cells my hikes for the
vinckx detail and for muse docu is the
real simple interface between your
development in warm  en cnn traduction
infrastructure so by just use and then
you can install it say in 20 minutes to
some tape your server
this shows that server interview
lookalikes ar
en foil that was really really giving
so this is white gray
yes i games you have any questions on
duty spring of the day and hope you can
try iroko a document you will like it
gets really
and is a fence thanks a lot for your
attention